はい 知る世界の法則 これからなんですけど
テーマは 早く行きます
では 一切智者になりましょう
皆様もこれから勉強して一切智者になってみてください
知るという機能の法則を理解できたら
一切智者です 簡単です
知る場合は 眼耳鼻舌身意という六つの感覚器官で知るんです
法則でしょ これで知るんです
一つだけでも感覚器官がなければ生命ではありません
ただの物体です だからみんなに六つあるわけじゃないんですよね
例えばミミズはミミズだから耳もないし目もないでしょうね
二つ欠けてますよ でも一個だけでも必要なんです
アメーバには体の感覚しかないんです
一個しかないんです 我々には六つもついています
感覚器官を通して知る過程を
その法則を発見することが知る世界のすべてです
感覚器官を通してどうやって知っているのか
それを知ればもう全部知ってます
ちょっと真面目にやってみてください
やったらものすごい もう人の質問やら考え方やら概念やら
何であろうともテキパキと答え出せますよ
例えば 今の人を殺そうしているでしょうね
アメリカもヨーロッパ
あっちこっちからこれやめてくださいと頼んでいるんだけどね
あの人々は聞いてくれない
私だったらもう会うことも喋ることもできないんだけどね
その人々を見事に馬鹿にして見せますよ
馬鹿にするんじゃなくて
あなた方がその人を殺すことによって神を侮辱するんだと
コーランに逆らいますよということできます
情報をちゃんとデータ持って
それなぜかというと そんな自信があるのは
やっぱり法則を知ったらできますよ
一つはね 名前はどうであろうとも
本人たちは真面目に絶対的神を信仰している
だから絶対的神一人しかいないんだから
本物の神を信じているんですよ
名前違ったんだから何考えているんですかね
だからあなた方は神は二人いると思っているんだよと
この裁判を起こそうとするあなた方は
神二人の存在認めているんだよと
それはコーランで許せませんよと言えますよ
神一人しかいないと頑固と信じるならば
名前はアッラーであろうか
イエホワであろうか どうでもいいんです
もう一つ 神を侮辱したら地獄に落とすのは神の仕事です
人間には権利与えていないんです
人を裁けなさいと それでコーランに逆らっています
まずあなた方を裁きなさいということになります
だからそういうことなんですよ
結局は だから皆様でも感覚器官のこのシステムがわかっちゃえばね
もう全然心配することないんですよ
それで一個だけ説明します
目がありますね 目に色と形が見えるんですよ
目に見えるのは色と形
光見えるとは思わないでください
それは科学者のもう余計な説明で
我々に見えるのは光と形と色ですよ
光が目に入っちゃうと眩しくて見えないんです
形でなければ 例えば太陽見えるんではないかと
形見えるんです 星は見える
星の形見えるんです それに仏教専門用語で色と読むんですね
目に色が触れる 触れるんです
それを感じるんですよ
触れたと感じるんです
感じたものを知るんですよ
例えば星を見ると 星を見ているんじゃなくて
目に触れたあの光の粒を感じて
その感じたものを見ているんです
だから私が見る星と皆様が見る星が違うんですよ
残念ですけど だって私は今目も老化しているし
もう視力もそれほど良くないし
で これで若い子と一緒に視力がいいすごい立派な子供と一緒に
じゃあ星見ましょうと言っても
子供に見える子供の感覚と私の目の感覚って違うんですよ
知るのはその感覚なんですよ
空にある星じゃないんです
だから人それぞれ知る世界違うんです
外にあるものをそのまま見えるのではなく
見る人は感じたものを知るのです
その地に 見えた 視覚と名付けるんです
だから  10人まとめて 1本の花を見ると
大体皆様にこの花が見える
同じもの見えるんだけど
同じものの同じデータが目に触れてますけど
視覚は同じじゃないんです
それぞれ感じた範囲で知った
知った 見えた 見えたと言うんです
自分が見たから その知は正しいと思う
だから 自分に見えた花は正しいと思う
例えば これをぼやっとして
この花を見る人にとっては
もしかすると美しく映るかもしれませんよ
その人はすごく感動するかもしれませんが
なんて綺麗でしょうか
例えば この乱視の人々は
この街灯とかね まあイルミネーションとか見ると感動しますよ
乱視だからね 視覚はすっごいシャープな人にとっては別に面白くない
まあ光って消えて光って消えていくんだからね
よく例えばこの光がサーッと流れるような
この蛍光灯みたいな なんとかあるでしょ
あの看板とかね 光が流れるように見えるでしょ
あれ すっごいシャープな人ね
ものすごい体が健康な人には
ちっと見るとそう見えません
点滅だけ現れて消え 現れて消える
で 私にも子供頃は このいろんなイルミネーションで光が流れているような
いろんなものをやってますけど
見えなかったんです 一個一個別々に点滅して見える
消えるだけで それで大人たちがすごい綺麗でしょうね
俺がバカかな 綺麗に見えないんだとかね
すごく工夫するんですよ
これどうやって美しい
それで目の調整をわざと狂っちゃうんですよ
自分であの その時筋肉よろしいんだから
だからなんかぼやぼけるようにして見ていると
あ なるほど 流れてるんだなとかね
今は別に苦労しなくたっても流れるように見えますよ
もう弱いんです それで我々は知った世界に愛着
私が知ったんだからね
見たんだから何言うのかと怒ったりまでする
正しいと思う しかし 情報同じであっても
知はバラバラですね もうわかりますね
皆で猿そばを見ましょう
では 皆同じ 皆様に同じ認識が現れますかと
ちょっとイメージしてください
自分の目の前に猿そばがある
食べたばかりの人 お腹が空いている人
飢えている人 そば好きな人
嫌いな人 中国人 ベトナム人
アメリカ人など 認識同じですかね
認識 気持ち 反応は決して同一ではありません
でしょ 中国人がラーメンのプロたちだ
だからね 日本の猿そば見て何に考えるかとわからないでしょう
ベトナム人もラーメン民族だからね
こちらの猿そば見たら何感じるでしょうかね
アメリカ人はどう感じるのでしょうかね
それで日本人の間でもそばが嫌いな人がいたら
あるいはもう飢えているぐらいの人だったら
それぞれ認識が変わるんですよ
でもデータは同じですよ
データは同じだけど 認識バラバラ
では 誰が正しく見たんですかね
あのそばは アメリカ人
ベトナム人 日本人 そば好きな人
言えないでしょ 誰が正しいかと
誰の認識は間違ってますかね
言えませんでしょ うん
だったらなんで我々人類は知識世界に住んでいて
これほど喧嘩していますかね
宗教喧嘩 政治思想に対する喧嘩
親子喧嘩 夫婦喧嘩 戦争まで
もうあらゆる苦難 何であるんですかね
よく覚えておいてください
簡単に平和になりますよ
このシステムわかっちゃえば
バカバカらしくてたまらないんです
いつでもそばの例でも覚えておけば救われますよ
人生は 喧嘩しないですごく穏やかにいられます
宇宙の果てまで知らなくても
ただ猿そばのイメージでできます
平和を平和で安らぎな心で
清らかな心で 罪のない心でいることは
他人が知るように 認識するように
自分にも認識できますか？逆に
では 私がみんなの気持ちを理解してやろうと思ってもできる？例えば
そば嫌いな人はあると思います
そばを嫌いな人の気持ちを
そば好きな人にわかりますかね
わからないでしょうね
そば好きな人が見ただけで
ああ 美味しい美味しいとよだれが出るしね
そば嫌いな人はどんな気持ちになるかと
どう頑張ってもわからない
だから余計なことをしてはいけません
あなたの気持ちはわかってるんだそうとかね
トラブルが来るんですよ
しかし 誰も正しくないし
間違ってもいない 自分が感じたものを知るだけ
それは主観というものです
主観は真理ではありません
これまたキーワード 私に見えるんだから本物だというのはとんでもない話
同じ法則を 耳 間違ったっけ？耳と声
鼻と香り 舌と味 体と触れる
情報ね そのセットに合わせて適用して観察してほしいんです
私は説明したのは目のセクションだけ
また 5つあります 次は別に書いたんです
意と法も同じ法則です
意っていうのは心ですね
心に情報を いろんな概念やら触れて考えちゃうんですよ
心の場合は過去のことも考えられます
将来のことも想像できる
あることも想像 考える
ないことも考えられますから
心のデータは法と言うんですよ
法とは心の対象のことです
限りなく考える 妄想する
そちらにも対象があるんです
人が限りなく妄想するでしょう
考えるでしょう やっぱりちゃんと対象があって妄想するんです
自分の思考に一番執着愛着するから
妄想からの悩み苦しみは強烈です
猿そば見て食べ食べたいんだけど
今講演中だから食べられなくて苦しんじゃうでしょ
そんなのはどうったこと
どうった苦しみじゃないんですよ
自分の思考から出てくる苦しみはね
それは大変な強烈 精神的に病気になります
だからポイントは同じ
見えても見えても正しいと言えない
自分に見える主観だけ
聞いても正しく聞こえない
自分に聞こえた音だけ
主観だけ考えても 自分の主観だけ事実ではありません
しかし 誰一人も同じことを妄想しませんでしょ？私はあの人悪い人やと思ってますよと言っても
みんなその人を悪いと言ってないでしょうに
だからただの妄想ですよ
えーと このようにありのままに見ると
六 六つの感覚器官から生まれる認識は主観であることが発見できるんです
知っても知っても主観です
変です 間違いです 主観とは
ある個人だけの知る世界です
個人には自分の主観しかないから
知っても知っても主観です
知っても知っても真理を発見できず
夢中でいるんです 主観から解放しなくてはならないんです
だからこれがすごいんです
ここまでわかったら平和でいられます
それから解放する方法
目は無常 常に変化するでしょう
だから何でも感じられますよ
目は固定するんだったら
一つ感じちゃうと もうそれで終わっちゃうんです
でも次から次へとスーッと変わるんだから
見える見えるたびに目が変わるんですよ
感覚が 時々強烈な光を見ちゃうと何秒か見えないでしょ
あの感覚が強烈で変わるために時間かかるんですよ
だから眩しくて目が見えなくなっちゃうんです
だから見えるということは
目が無常ということなんです
無常がものすごいスピードが速いんだったら
すごい見えるんですよ
だから無常であってほしいんですよ
本当は みんな無常は嫌いですけどね
目が無常だから見える
で 色は無常です 常に変化する
だから目で感じることができるんです
見えるもの データも光もすーっと変わるんでしょ
でなきゃ見えないんです
ちょっと操作が違う 視覚は無常
常に変化する だから次から次へと知ることができる
例えば こちら見るわ こちら見るわ
こちら見るわと 見えるでしょうに
見えたら視覚でしょ これ
例えばスピーカーを見てください
スピーカー見たら視覚が生まれますよ
それから別のスクリーンを見てください
見えるでしょ？視覚も変わったんですよ
変わらなかったらスクリーン見てもスピーカーしか見えません
そんなことないでしょ
すごい速さで視覚も変化していくんです
だから次から次に知ることができる
知は瞬間的なものですから
知るということはそんなに大げさなことじゃない
瞬間的なもの しかし主観です
それも主観です あまりかっこよくない
普遍的な真理でもありません
その知識に それから現れる感情に愛着しては固執してはならない
ただそれだけなんです
放っておけばいいんです
こんなのは無常だからね
またかえって主観だからね
執着しない 固執しない
そう それで解脱になるんです
悟りになるんです すごいシンプルですけどね
見えたものは見えただけでもうあんまり執着しない
聞こえたものは聞いただけで執着しない
だから最終的なポイントは執着しない
あの知は治らないんですよ
目がある限り見える しかし
それ正しくないんだから
主観だからね 放っておく
勝手にしろよと 目に あんたも無常でしょうし
見えるものも無常でしょうし
視覚も無常でしょうと
そんなものに構っていられないんだと
全部執着してるんです
6つの感覚器官については
このような公式で観察して
無常たるものについて
因縁によって現れるものについて
執着を捨てて解放自由を目指すのです
全部からくりやと 全部この因縁だと
まあ無常やと 瞬間やと
何も固定したものはないんだぞと
だから何に欲張るのかと
いい例で言えば シャボン玉は綺麗でしょ
確かに だからって誰が執着するんですね
シャボン玉に じゃあ綺麗なシャボン玉
じゃあ持っていくぞとかね
置物にしてやるぞと誰も思わないでしょう
無常だから だからシャボン玉を楽しむのは楽なんですよ
あの壺なんか買ってきて楽しむ場合はビクビクするんです
盗まれたらどうしようかと
だから無常は楽しむとすごい楽です
それで執着したら心は自由になるんです
それは解脱という世界なんです
正しくない知によって
人は執着を捨てず 無限に輪廻転生しながら苦しむんです
解放ができた人は一切の苦しみからも解放される
だからこの問題解決したら
苦しみの循環は破ったことになります
知識を捨てた人に 何でも知り得る智慧が現れるんです
知識捨てたら 主観捨てたらもう何でも知ってます
6つの感覚器官を悟ることは
一切智者になる方法なのです
主観に対する執着を捨てると
必要なものならそれを知る能力があるんです
怖がらないでください
知識捨てたら馬鹿になるんではないかと
逆 何でも知ることができます
知りたければなんです
知る必要あれば もうちょい例
三角形の面積を計算する公式を知っているならば
どのような三角形の面積も計算できるでしょう
世界中あるありとあらゆる三角形の計算してなくてもいいでしょうに
公式だけ知れば 必要な時計算する
必要でなかったら たとえ三角形があっても別に無視する
関係ないんだぞと このように悟りを開いた人に何でも知ることができるが
必要なもの以外無駄に挑戦しないんです
これで終わると思います
一応 感覚器官の法則を知る人には
なんでなんかこの 疲れてますかね
感覚器官の法則を知る人には悩み
苦しみはありません 主観
固定概念 妄想から生まれる無意味な苦しみから脱出しましょうということで
すごいシンプルですよ
難しく喋ったんだけど
また はい そういうことで
どうもありがとうございます
皆さん ご静聴ありがとうございました
今日は回向の文をあげたいと思います
回向の文 ...仏法僧の三宝に礼拝し
帰依をのり 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして 苦悩が減らされますように
サッビーティオイワッジャンツーサッブロウゴウウィナッサトーマテーバワットワンタラーヨースケーディーガーユコーバワ
バワトゥサッバマンガランラッカントゥサッバデーワタサッバブンダヌバーヴェーナサッバダンマアヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ
サダーソッティーバワントゥテーアーユラーローギャサンプティーサッガサンプティーメーウェッチャ
アトーニッバーナサンプティーミナーテーサミッジャトゥ
サーーリサーーリサーーリ
どうしても質問がある方々は隣のゴータミー精舎がありますので
そちらで集めて まあ質問とかね
聞いてもよろしいんです
はい ではどうもありがとうございます